At their very best,
technologies of media
are engines of empathy.
Cinema, perhaps the
pinnacle, the cathedral
of communication
technology, allows
you to experience the world
from another's point of view,
ultimately at its best
acting as a catalyst for you
to be more compassionate and
empathic towards the other.
Now, looking towards the
future, there's a lot of talk
now about virtual reality.
The Oculus Rift has
finally captured
the imagination of the public.
And this is now
becoming real, the idea
of fully immersive,
technologically mediated dream
worlds, rendered mind spaces
where you literally inhabit
another world, portals
to another world.
These are not virtual realities.
These are going to
be real virtualities.
And what is this
ultimately all about?
Well, Terence McKenna
says, these technologies
will allow us to share our
dreams with one another.
Everybody will have essentially
a cosmos of the imagination
where they can build
cathedrals of the mind.
Imagine the intimacy
that becomes possible
when people meet and they say
hey, do you want to come visit
my world.
Do you want to see what it's
like to be inside my head?
What kind of intimacy?
It's like turning
ourselves inside out.
The metaphor used by Terence
McKenna is that of the octopi.
This is what becomes possible.
The octopi transfigurates to
merge with its environment.
It literally wears
its linguistic intent
outside its skin.
It wears its mind, its nervous
system, outside its skin.
Its way of communicating is
something that can be beheld.
Language becomes something
that can be visually beheld.
Us humans, you know--
grunts, and voices,
and funny faces to try to
imbue, to read what one another
is thinking and feeling,
imagine if with virtual reality,
we all become like
octopi and wear
our minds outside our skin.
Imagine the intimacy
that becomes possible.
This is really what excites
me about virtual reality,
about these sacred
modalities of intimacy
exchanging shared
intersubjectivity that
become possible.
Think about that.